the author of trumped-up how
criminalization of political differences
in dangers democracy Harvard
Constitutional Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz
Fox News contributor Sarah Carter
Judicial Watch president Tom Benton
Sarah because you have been on the
forefront this week we now know that the
dossier bought and paid for by Hillary
with salacious lies was used to get a
FISA warrant against well yes we now
know that it was either in part used or
it was a significant part of the FBI
being able to get the warrant to spy on
Trump and people within his campaign but
Shawn when you're looking at the dossier
and I think actually linking Glenn
Simpsons testimony actually backfired on
the Democrats I mean it really did you
look at that testimony you see to
yourself first Glenn Simpson said there
was a source inside the Trump campaign
that's proven to be false now what what
people have corrected that version of it
and said well no he was just talking
about George papadopolis in London then
you find out that Glenn Simpson wouldn't
answer any questions as to whether he
was pushing this dossier to the media he
kept stepping back he wouldn't answer it
then we find out he didn't even verify
the information in the dossier and when
you look at all of this knowing that the
Hillary Clinton campaign and the DNC
actually paid for this paid for this
dossier and that the dossier itself
could have been part of a ginormous a
huge a huge disinformation came by the
rep by the Russians I mean it's it's
clearly there's a problem professor let
me go to you and you make some really
good points as you reservoir lates the
the partisan aspect of all this now I'm
a conservative more proud conservative I
don't hide any of that but we we learned
a lot that the fix was in I want to use
this analogy that the fix was in poor
Bernie Sanders and his supporters they
had no shot at all whatsoever and even
got a Brazil admits that then you have
Comey and struck I don't believe I've
ever heard of a case we write
exoneration letters months before you
interview the people involved in an
investigation they didn't do the
investigation but they're writing in
exoneration then it seems with the
Russian dossier that they're trying to
put the fix in
there by using bought and paid for
Russian propaganda we now learn and then
you take it a step further and that
information was put before a FISA Court
and a warrant issued as a constitutional
scholar I hope you are as afraid as I am
about these issues about the the corrupt
nature of all of this and the Const and
our constitutional rights in jeopardy
here I am very much worried about that
that's why I called for right from the
beginning an impartial nonpartisan
Commission of Inquiry to look into every
aspect of the last election every aspect
what the Russians try to do in terms of
the Democrats what the Russians try to
do in terms of the Republicans this is a
bipartisan issue every American suffers
when the Russians in any way try to
influence the election look I don't
think the Russians try to influence the
election necessarily in favor of one
candidate or the other I think they try
to influence the election in terms of
destabilizing the American political
system and that's why having partisan
inquiries by congressional committees
doesn't work that's why having a special
counsel who operates behind closed doors
doesn't work we need an open
investigation Commission this is too
important to all Americans to leave to
any kind of partisan advantage let me
let me follow up with the dossier we
paid was partisan bought and paid for
remember
Christopher Steele didn't come on board
with Fusion until Hillary and the DNC
we're paying for it but that dossier
used to obtain at least in part maybe
significantly as Sarah's reporting to
get a FISA warrant on a opposition
candidate and a president-elect seems
like a Fourth Amendment crisis here in
many ways well I think it would be a
Fourth Amendment violation if the
material in the FISA warrant were known
to be false now under a case called
Franks versus Maryland it's not enough
under the Fourth Amendment for it to be
wrong it has to be known to be wrong and
so again this should be looked into
every fact should be investigated nobody
should be afraid of the truth let the
truth come out let the inheritors
and inside but can I say one more thing
I'm sorry just one more thing I know
it's not on topic but you know as the
grandchild of American immigrants who
came from a very very poor country in
Europe I hope the president will
apologize for whatever he said that
demeans immigrants the Statute of
Liberty says give us your poor your
hungry people yearning to be free we are
a country of immigrants and I just hope
we can elevate the discussion about
immigration and try not to insult people
from any part of the world and the
president can do a great service if he
just comes forward and admit today and
this is tough language vote but he
denied what dirt but we're gonna get
into this later in the show but he
denied what Durbin said it's sonny
Perdue and another senator in the room
said they didn't hear it but it doesn't
much matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what words he used I think this
rest was a thrust against certain
countries and we just can't have that
kind of attitude it makes us look very
bad in the world and it really undercuts
what our Statue of Liberty has long
stood for Sarah I am before I get to
town I'm not trying to keep getting town
but I want to just follow up in
something that the professor Terzi which
was saying I have one source I don't
have till that actually told me that
there was one confirmation as a relates
to the dossier and I was given a name
and it happens to be somebody that is a
corrupt individual inside the clintons
circles and you know you can tell about
your face you know exactly what I'm
talking about I know exactly who you're
talking about
and if that does come to fruition if if
we find out then the court may have been
lied to
then the court may have been lied to and
then what Alan Dershowitz said would
definitely take significance Tom tell us
what the Judicial Watch is doing well
you know I think there's gonna be it's
ours indicating it's Namie of
information coming out or all these
scandals we have the court ruling that
the Clinton emails need to be released
more quickly so we're gonna get all
these Clinton emails that she tried to
hide or delete these were the ones to
lead it's a and we haven't seen any of
them yet yeah that looks like they may
all be about yoga wedding a funeral and
more as we bill who doesn't email or we
found on the Weiner laptop class
find information and pay-to-play which I
guarantee is going to be coming out and
then we had to court just yesterday talk
about how he wants the Kobe memos
because he wants to review the Comey
memos which are the genesis of the
Mueller operation there would be no
Miller a special prosecutor but for the
leaking of Comey to the New York Times
on one specific memo so that material
may be coming out it's all it's all
building and there are text messages
that are coming out and as that it's
talking about now we're gonna find out
more details about the FISA or the fun
of the the intelligence surveillance
abuses now you know what concern is that
why are we waiting to find out about
them after the reauthorization occurs I
would suggest we find out about the
abuses before they reauthorize this for
another six you know I'll let you report
on this but you know no I mean of course
yet Devon Nunez is going to after after
they rule on the FISA Act which
surprised going to pass is going to
disclose what actually these the about
densive abuse tenses abuse yeah in the
Department of Justice and with the FBI
and I gotta tell you this this is coming
from people within the intelligence
community this system has been abused it
has been a view abused viciously and we
know from what we've seen right we know
from what we've seen that there needs to
be an investigation but let's do it
before let's do it for the professor for
did professor Dershowitz uh yeah what
that what debe nudists is saying that
there is clear evidence of massive abuse
of government surveillance by the FBI
and Department of Justice officials I
don't know he's a libertarian first and
foremost sir
yeah yeah yeah at we we civil
libertarians liberals and conservatives
alike have long worried about the FBI
its surveillance methods and the
potential for abuse remember Comey not
only leaked he laundered the information
through a columbia law professor he
didn't have the courage to stand up in
front of a TV camera and say this is
information that i'm gonna give you
because i want a special counsel to be
appointed he laundered it through a
Columbia professor these are issues that
shall be investigated
we have to know what surveillance is
being used against Americans and whether
you're a conservative or a liberal or a
Republican or a Democrat you compare
deeply about any abuse of this process
if you believe in the Constitution and
our constitutional rights
nobody should disagree with that last
worked on Hillary Clinton and her top
campaign aides need to be brought in at
least by Congress to testify about what
they knew and when about this dossier
glen simpson refused to talk about
whether the clinton campaign his
paymaster what his their involvement was
in directing Krystal's use of russian
intelligence to gather information a lot
of news coming next week Oh a lot of
news come in next week Charlotte